after five days of grief and anger there
was huge anticipation surrounding this
moment the first charge is felony murder
this is a death that is as a result of a
underlying felony and in this case the
underlying felony is aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon and the possible
sentences for a felony murder conviction
would be life life without parole or the
death penalty its Garrett Rolfe who
fired the fatal shots at Rashard Brooks
who now faces that prospect with a total
of 11 charges devin Brosnan the other
officer at the scene faces three charges
he will now act as a witness in the case
this police footage formed a big part of
the charge decisions it all began when
the officers responded to a report of a
man sleeping in his car at a fast-food
drive-through their body cameras show
Rashard Brooks chatting cooperatively
with them the district attorney
described him as almost jovial he went
on to fail a breathalyzer test
after 41 minutes and 17 seconds of calm
things changed when the officers tried
to handcuff him for suspected
drink-driving
the three is seen fighting on the ground
before Brooks grabs an officer's taser
and runs away he points the Taser over
his shoulder officer Rolf then shoots
him multiple times prosecutors say he
then kicked Rashard Brooks as he lay
dying on the ground the other officer
stood on his shoulder for over two
minutes both men failed to provide any
treatment you would kick another human
being after you just put two bullets in
his back but even in dark times like
this you have to try and see the light
and the positivity of this situation is
the courageousness of officer Brosnan to
step forward and say what happened was
wrong
this police killing came in the middle
of national protests over police
brutality against black Americans Donald
Trump has been criticized for his
response to it which included a violent
crackdown on peaceful protesters outside
the White House to make way for this
political stunt speaking to K Burleigh
his 2016 rival Hillary Clinton slammed
his handling of this crisis they were
totally peaceful protesters and what he
was trying to do as he often does is to
mischaracterize them and their behavior
and their goals and lock them in with a
tiny tiny minority of people who took
advantage of a tragic moment to loot and
to steal and to vandalize a tiny tiny
percentage and he wanted to cast that
over the millions of you know very
thoughtful nonviolent peaceful
protesters who thanks a opportunity yeah
well if absolutely for a photo
opportunity holding a book he's never
read he says that it's one of his
favorite books yes and he can't tell you
a single thing that's in it that has
been a pattern he's tried to hijack
Christianity and the Bible in ways that
are you know deeply hypocritical
the movement may take some piece from
today's charges but it also highlights
how deep this problem runs and how much
it's going to take to end this
devastating cycle Amanda Walker Sky News
Washington